en asie si l'épizootie de grippe aviaire
poursuit toujours son offensive les
spécialistes redoutent désormais
qu'elles ne se transforment en épidémie
humaine à grande échelle comme la grippe
espagnole qui fit plusieurs dizaines de
millions de morts au début du 20e siècle
les scientifiques cherchent un vaccin et
c'est peut-être dans un cimetière
britannique qu'ils pourraient trouver la
solution
jennifer alberte philippe berne n'a que
20 ans lorsque la grippe espagnole
l'emportent en 1918 un virus de la même
famille que celui de la grippe aviaire
qui touche actuellement l'asie
c'est cette parenté que les
scientifiques aimeraient étudiée mais le
virus de la grippe espagnole a été
éradiquée alors il va falloir exhumer le
corps de philippe b on s'est rendu
compte qu'on pouvait effectivement tenir
des informations médicales importantes à
partir du corps de cette personne on a
alors demandé l'autorisation de
l'exhumer à sa famille et aux autorités
religieuses qui nous ont accordé au
sortir de la grande guerre la grippe
espagnole des cimes une partie de la
population mondiale 20 millions de
personnes peut être le double phyllis
byrne est morte il ya 85 ans si cette
issue ne sont pas altérées les
chercheurs prélèveront des échantillons
de poumons pour décoder l'empreinte
génétique de la grippe espagnole six
gènes du virus ont déjà été identifiés à
partir d'autres échantillons plus petit
l'intérêt grippe espagnole et grippe
aviaire se ressemblent génétiquement
les chercheurs ont de grandes chances de
trouver quelque chose
ils ont déjà des cônes et une partie de
la séquence adn de la grippe espagnole
s'il déconne toute la séquence ils
pourront la combiner avec celle de la
grippe aviaire pour fabriquer un vaccin
un laboratoire britannique a d'ailleurs
fait venir du vietnam
le virus de la grippe du poulet le monde
scientifique s'inquiète qu'elles ne se
transmettent à l'homme et qu'elle ne
devienne aussi dévastatrice que la
grippe espagnole au début du siècle